THE RIOTS AND ROMAN PARTY.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
NOW, IMAGINE IF THOUSANDS OF
LET’S SAY PRO-LIFE CHRISTIANS
DECIDED TO SURROUND A FEDERAL
COURTHOUSE IN TEXAS WHERE
PRO-ABORTION RIGHTS CASES HAD
RECENTLY BEEN DECIDED?
I IMAGINE OF THESE PROTESTERS,
BUT OTHERS CAME TO CAUSE REAL
TROUBLE.
IMAGINE IF THEY THREW BOTTLES OF
CEMENT, BRICKS, AND SHOT
FIREWORKS.
IMAGINE IF THEY USED LASERS AT
FEDERAL OFFICIALS WHO WERE
PROTECTING THE BUILDING.
IMAGINE THEY MADE MOLOTOV
COCKTAILS AND SET CARS UMPIRES
AND THAT THEY DID THIS NIGHT
AFTER NIGHT AFTER NIGHT.
THEN IMAGINE IF REPUBLICAN
ELECTED OFFICIALS IN THE STATE
NOT ONLY REFUSED TO END THE
VIOLENCE, BUT ACTUALLY TRIED TO
BLAME A SITTING DEMOCRAT
PRESIDENT FOR INFLAMING TENSIONS
BY SENDING FEDERAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND TO PROTECT
THE FEDERAL PROPERTY AND THE
FEDERAL STAFF WORKING INSIDE.
NOW, HOW DO YOU THINK THE MEDIA
WOULD BE COVERING THAT
SITUATION?
WATCH.
SPEAK WITH THE PROTESTERS, THE
PROTESTERS THEY CALL SELFISH,
DANGEROUS AND OUT-OF-CONTROL.
THE PRESS WOULD DEMONS DEMONIZED
THOSE PROTESTERS IN DEMAND THEY
WOULD BE PROSECUTED TO THE
FULLEST EXTENT OF THE LAW.
BUT REMEMBER WHEN MICHIGAN
CITIZENS HELD PEACEFUL PROTEST
TO REOPEN BUSINESSES A FEW
MONTHS AGO.
THE MEDIA TREATED THEM WITH
UTTER DISGUST.
>> SO WE HAVE VIDEO TODAY
GOVERNOR WHITMER OUTSIDE OF THE
CAPITAL WITH PROTEST AND YOU CAN
SEE PEOPLE STANDING ON THE
STEPS, PEOPLE TALKING AND I WANT
TO GET CLEAR MOST PEOPLE WERE IN
THEIR CARS BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE
ARE STANDING AROUND, SOME NOT
WEARING MASKS.
DO YOU THINK THE PROTEST PUT
PEOPLE AT RISK TODAY?
>> ABSOLUTELY, ABSOLUTELY.
>> Laura: OVER THE PAST MONTH,
WE HAVE SEEN NONSTOP VIOLENCE IN
MAJOR CITIES AND BLUE STATES
ACROSS AMERICA.
NOW PORTLAND, OREGON, IS ABOUT A
GROUND WITH CRIMINALS ATTEMPTING
TO TAKE OVER AND BURN DOWN A
FEDERAL BUILDING.
[CHANTING]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Laura: THIS HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH GEORGE FLOYD APPEARED IT
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH RACIAL
JUSTICE.
THIS IS ABOUT REAL POWER AND
POLITICIANS AND BLUE STATES,
THEY DECIDED THAT THE RIOTS ARE
HELPING THEM POLITICALLY.
THEY ARE LOOKING AT THE POLLS
AND THEY THINK THAT OPPOSING
ANYTHING AND EVERYTHING THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP DOES OR SAYS IS
MORE POLITICALLY ADVANTAGEOUS
THAN OPPOSING THESE CRIMINALS.
>> THEIR FORCES ARE NOT NEEDED
HERE.
THEY WERE NOT WANTED HERE.
AND THEY ARE MAKING A
CHALLENGING SITUATION WORSE.
>> THEY LOOK A WHOLE LOT LIKE
PROTESTERS FROM THE FAR RIGHT TO
COME TO MAKE TROUBLE.
>> CRIME IN PORTLAND AND ACROSS
OREGON WAS DOWN BEFORE
DONALD TRUMP SENT IN THE SECRET
POLICE.
>> THEN THESE GUYS CAME IN LIKE
A BULLDOZER.
IT IS A DISASTER, THE
ADMINISTRATION IS MAKING.
>> Laura: AND OF COURSE, THE
MEDIA, THEY ARE SO POLLUTED WITH
ANTI-TRUMP BIASED THEY DON’T
BOTHER TO HIDE IT ANYMORE.
>> THESE PEACEFUL PROTESTS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WERE ENDED
WITH VIOLENCE OVER THE WEEKEND
INFLAMED BY PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
PLAN TO EMPLOY MORE FEDERAL
AGENTS.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP CONTINUING TO
FOCUS PERHAPS ON THE VOLATILE.
>> JUST THROWING GAS ON THE
FIRE.
THE PRESIDENT WITH MILITARY
TROOPS IN PORTLAND AGAINST THE
WISHES OF CITY AND STATE LEADERS
HAS VERY MUCH INFLAME TENSIONS,
AND THERE ARE HUNDREDS IF NOT
THOUSANDS OF ORDINARY CITIZENS
WHO COME HERE DAY AFTER DAY TO
PEACEFULLY AND RACIAL JUSTICE.
>> Laura: SORRY, BUT ORDINARY
CITIZENS DO NOT PROTEST AFTER
DARK, SHOOTING OFF MORTAR STYLE
FIREWORKS AT LAW ENFORCEMENT.
I LOVE HOW SHE SAID PARAMILITARY
FORCES TOO, THAT WAS SWEET.
PEACEFUL PROTESTERS PER MONTH BY
THE WAY DON’T TIRE ROPES TO
FENCES OR STATUES OR STAY OUT
TILL 3:00 A.M. TO SET FIRE TO A
FEDERAL BUILDING.
THEY DON’T DO THAT.
REPORTERS USED TO KNOW THAT.
NOW, AGAIN, IMAGINE
CONSERVATIVES UPSET BY THE
INJUSTICE OF ABORTION WERE UPSET
BY THE SCHOOL CLOSURES OR
ANYTHING FOR THAT MATTER.
IMAGINE IF THEY DID ANYTHING
CLOSE TO THIS.
WOULD ABC’S TWEET READ LIKE THIS
ONE FROM LAST NIGHT THAT
PROTESTERS IN CALIFORNIA SET
FIRE TO A COURTHOUSE, DAMAGED A
POLICE STATION, AND ASSAULTED
OFFICERS AFTER A PEACEFUL
DEMONSTRATION INTENSIFIED?
IS THAT WHAT WE ARE CALLING IT?
INTENSIFIED!
AND BY THE WAY, STOP CALLING
THEM PROTESTERS.
THEY ARE VIOLENT REVOLUTIONARIES
TRYING TO OVERTHROW OUR
GOVERNMENT AND IN THE INTERIM,
THEY ARE BASICALLY TRYING TO
INTIMIDATE YOU THE VOTERS TO
SUPPORT BIDEN OR ELSE.
AND THE MORE COVER THEY GET FROM
DEMOCRAT ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
THE MEDIA, THE MORE THEY WILL
FAN OUT ACROSS OTHER LIBERAL
HAVENS IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND NOW I’M A ONE OF THEIR
FAVORITE UNLAWFUL TACTICS IS TO
BLOCK FEDERAL INTERSTATES OR
OTHER MAJOR THOROUGHFARES USED
BY LAW-ABIDING MOTORIST IN ORDER
TO TERRORIZE THOSE PEOPLE AND
THEN POST THE VIDEO ON
SOCIAL MEDIA.
NOW, THEY TRIED THIS ON THE KEY
BRIDGE THAT CONNECTS ROSSLYN
VIRGINIA TO GEORGETOWN AND
WASHINGTON OVER THE WEEKEND
WHERE, AGAIN, PEACEFUL
PROTESTERS SURROUNDED A WOMAN’S
CAR, BLOCKING HER FROM DRIVING
THROUGH, AND THEN THEY BEGAN
EATING IT WITH THEIR HANDS AND
OTHER OBJECTS.
THEN, THEY POSTED THIS VIDEO,
THIS PHOTO OF THE ELDERLY WOMAN
BEHIND THE WHEEL OF HER CAR AND
THEN SHOWED HER LICENSE PLATE.
SHE WAS TERRORIZED IN HER CAR
FOR 45 MINUTES.
THEY DID THIS IN AURORA,
COLORADO OUTSIDE OF DENVER WHEN
A JEEP DROVE DOWN THE HIGHWAY
BLOCKED BY MORE, PEACEFUL
PROTESTERS.
>> A CAR JUST RAN THROUGH.
THERE WERE SHOTS.
WE DON’T KNOW WHAT KIND OF SHOTS
SHOTS.
>> Laura: GUNSHOTS WERE FIRED,
AND THIS IS GETTING COMPLETELY
OUTRAGEOUS, EXTREMELY DANGEROUS
SITUATION DEVELOPING.
MOTORISTS EITHER STOP AND
SUBJECT THEMSELVES TO
POTENTIALLY VIOLENT ATTACKS BY
CRIMINALS THAT ARE SURROUNDING
THEIR VEHICLE, OR THEY CONTINUE
DRIVING AND THEN THEY PUT LIVES
IN DANGER.
SO IT’S LIKE A CATCH-22 IF YOU
ARE A DRIVER COMING INTO ONE OF
THE SITUATIONS.
THEN IN AUSTIN, TEXAS, THE
PROTESTER GARY FOSTER WAS SHOT
AND KILLED AFTER HE APPROACHED
THE DRIVER SIDE OF A VEHICLE
WHILE HE WAS CARRYING AN AK-47.
[GUNSHOTS FIRED]
>> Laura: NOW I WANT EVERYONE
TO UNDERSTAND THIS TONIGHT.
DEMOCRATS ARE ALLOWING THIS TO
HAPPEN ACROSS AMERICA.
IN FACT, I WILL GO FURTHER AND I
WILL SAY MANY GREEN LIGHTING
THIS.
THEY LITERALLY FIGHT HARDER TO
KEEP PEOPLE FROM GOING TO CHURCH
OR OUTSIDE OF PICNICKING THAN
THEY DO DO AGAINST THIS
LAWLESSNESS.
THE ONLY SPOKEN OFFER THAT I
THINK DEMOCRATS ARE MAKING THE
VOTERS THIS NOVEMBER IS THE
FOLLOWING: VOTE TRUMP OUT OF
OFFICE AND WE WILL PUT AN END TO
THIS.
BUT I’M TELLING YOU, IF YOU
REWARD THIS, YOU WERE GOING TO
GET A LOT MORE, NOT A LOT LESS
OF THIS.
AND GOING FORWARD, IT IS GOING
TO GET MORE VIOLENT AND THE
INTIMIDATION, THAT WOULD JUST
METASTASIZE AND CONSUME THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY.
IT WILL CONTINUE UNTIL DEMOCRATS
FEEL THAT IT IS HURTING THEM
POLITICALLY.
BY THE WAY, WHERE IS JOE BIDEN?
WHY DOESN’T HE HAVE THE DECENCY
OR FRANKLY THE PRESENCE OF MIND
TO SPEAK AGAINST THIS AND
FORCEFULLY DAY AFTER DAY?
WHY HASN’T HE TOLD US WHAT HE
WOULD DO TO STOP THE ONGOING
DESTRUCTION OF PUBLIC PROPERTY
AND THE ENDANGERING OF LIVES?
REMEMBER, JOE, SILENCE IS
VIOLENCE, RIGHT?
THE DEMOCRATS ARE WORKING IN
LOCKSTEP WITH EACH OTHER THE
POLITICIANS.
AFTER A CITY LIKE SEATTLE LOST
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN REVENUE AND COUNTLESS JOBS
DUE TO VIOLENCE, THEY STILL
DON’T CARE.
SEATTLE DISMANTLED THAT CHOP
ZONE, REMEMBER LAST MONTH?
THIS PAST WEEKEND THE CHAOS
RETURN APPEARANCE A WEB COURSE,
THIS IGNORANT FOOL OF A MAYOR
JENNY DURKAN BLAMED TRUMP.
THE PRESIDENT’S ACTIONS CLEARLY
HAVE ESCALATED THINGS IN SEATTLE
AND ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
I WAS JUST TALKING TO A NUMBER
OF MAYORS THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY
WHO SAW A SIMILAR THING THAT
PEOPLE WANTING TO ACT OUT
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION COMING TO THE
STREETS.
>> Laura: WAIT, WHAT ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT?
THEY WERE SMASHING THE WINDOWS
OF LIBERAL STARBUCKS.
I MEAN, ARE THERE ACTUAL VOTERS
WHO ARE ACTUALLY BUYING WHAT
MAYORS LIKE DURKIN ARE SAGGING?
>> WE HAD A NUMBER OF PEACEFUL
PROTESTERS AND WHAT WE HAVE SEEN
IS EVERY TIME THIS PRESIDENT
PROMISES TO SO DIVISION, HE IS
SUCCESSFUL AT IT.
I HATE TO SAY IT, AARON, I
BELIEVE WE ARE SEEING A DRY RUN
FOR MARTIAL LAW.
>> Laura: [LAUGHTER]
AGAIN, ALL OUT OF THE PLAYBOOK.
HER OWN POLICE FORCE DECLARED
SEATTLE A RIOT OVER THE WEEKEND.
AND SHE STILL IS CALLING IT A
PEACEFUL PROTEST?
NOW DONALD TRUMP KNOWS THAT NO
U.S. PRESIDENT SHOULD SIT IDLY
BY AND ALLOW THIS DESTRUCTION TO
CONTINUE.
HE KNOWS THAT WE NEED TO SUPPORT
STATE AND LOCAL LAW AND FEDERAL
BY THE WAY FEDERAL OFFICERS AND
PROSECUTE THESE DOMESTIC
TERRORISTS OR THESE CRIMINALS WE
WE WILL GET THIS EVERY ELECTION
SEASON.
IN FACT, JUST MINUTES BEFORE THE
SHOW STARTED, THE DOJ ANNOUNCED
22 RIOTERS WERE ARRESTED, AND
THAT THEY FACE FEDERAL CHARGES
FOR THEIR ROLES IN SETTING FIRE
TO THE COURTHOUSE IN PORTLAND.
THAT IS GOOD NEWS.
AND I HAVE TO SAY, THERE ARE
SOME SIGNS THAT THE COUNTRY HAVE
HAD ABOUT ENOUGH OF THESE BROKEN
STOP BOLSHEVIKS THEY ARE HURTING
THE PEOPLE THEY CLAIM TO CARE SO
MUCH ABOUT, TRASHING
BUSINESSES AND PRIVATE PROPERTY.
>> 45 YEARS I’VE BEEN BLACK.
THIS IS A "BLACK LIVES MATTER"
THEM I’M NOT WAITING.
>> Laura: THEY TRASHED HER
CAR.
THE ONLY MODE OF TRANSPORTATION.
I’M SORRY, BUT THE CLAIM THAT
SOMEHOW THE PRESIDENT BY
STEPPING IN IS TRYING TO STIR
THE POT IS A FLAT OUT LIE.
YOU ARE BETTER THAN BEING LIED
TO.
DON’T ACCEPT THIS.
IT WOULD BE FAR EASIER AND
PERHAPS LESS POLITICALLY RISKY
TO LET PORT NUMBER AND APPEAR
THEY WANT TO BURN, BURN.
BUT TO DO SO WOULD VIOLATE THE
PRESIDENTIAL OATH OF OFFICE AND
TRUMP WAS NOT GOING TO DO THAT.
THE DEMOCRATS HAVE MADE A
CALCULATED DECISION TO FORM
COMMON CAUSE WITH THESE
MODERN-DAY MAOISTS.
THEY WANT ONE PARTY RULES JUST
LIKE THEY HAVE IN CALIFORNIA
EXCEPT EVEN FURTHER TO THE LEFT
OF CALIFORNIA.
THEY WANT MONOPOLY POWER THAT
LASTS FOR DECADES.
AND YOU WILL PAY THE PRICE.
SO THE QUESTION IS, WHAT ARE WE,
THE PEOPLE, GOING TO DO ABOUT
IT?
HOW LONG DO YOU INTEND TO BE
SILENT?
WHETHER YOU ARE A NATIVE BORN
AMERICAN OR AN IMMIGRANT COMIC
YOU DON’T WORK AS HARD AS YOU WO
TO HAVE YOUR BUSINESSES BURN
DOWN, TO HAVE YOUR KIDS FEEL
UNSAFE, OR TO BE THREATENED
BECAUSE YOU REFUSED TO CITE THE
LATEST RADICAL SLOGAN OF THE DAY
OR HAVE YOUR CAR SURROUNDED BY
ANTIFA OR OTHER RADICALS BECAUSE
YOU HAD THE NERVE TO TRY TO
DRIVE HOME, OR HEAVEN FORBID, TO
THE STORE TO GET SOMETHING.
IT IS TIME TO PUNISH THE
LAWBREAKERS, AND PUNISH THE
POLITICIANS AT THE BALLOT BOX
WHO ARE LETTING THIS UNREST